[Music]  Lily Collins gets candid about her  strange relationship with dad Phil  Collins in a new book of essays  unfiltered no shame no regrets just me  and at the twenty seven-year-old admits  her musician dad was often gone and when  she was five years old moved to  Switzerland after her parents divorced  she writes I became extra careful about  what I said and how I said it  afraid he think I was angry or didn't  love him and the truth is I was angry I  missed him and wanted him there and that  was et spoke with Phil in October he was  candid about how his problems with  alcohol also kept him away from his  family when I messed up I saw and that  stops in the chapter titled a letter to  all dads lily tells hers that she  forgives him quote I forgive you for not  always being there when I needed and for  not being the dad I expected I forgive  the mistakes you made